[Music]
i bet you we would all disagree about
what new means
and
one of the problems is that humans are
constantly innovating
all humans are makers of newness for
example that last sentence i said has
possibly never been said before
and probably you will or each of us in
this room will make at least
50 or 70 sentences today that nobody has
ever said before
that that means we are all of us
new and creative
[Music]
and
i had a shocking experience a few years
back there was a show of early early
20th century russian painting
at the barbican and i went along to the
show and discovered that
out of the 160 or so artists there
there were about 70 i'd never heard of
and they were just as good as the ones i
had heard of
and and i suddenly realized of course
that history drops certain people out
and elevates some names beyond others
all these people get forgotten
we're very used in the west to the idea
of genius the idea that certain people
who are very very gifted
and their thoughts sort of trickle down
to the rest of us
um
and we list those people like mozart and
beethoven and darwin and einstein and so
on
if you look at the lives of any of those
people you find that they were drawing
on a huge network of ideas of other
people who were around particularly in
early soviet russia this was the case
so i came up with this other word rather
than genius which is the
gift of an individual i came up with the
word cenius which is the gift of a whole
group of people of a community
and that has served me much betterism as
a way of understanding newness
of thinking of newness as something that
comes from a community
and that's a very important political
point as well because our politics for
the last 40 years have been directed
towards the idea that it's individuals
who matter not communities
[Music]